this is a phenomenal time to be a
curious person the information that's
out there but it has never been easier
so what are you waiting for I'm going to
give you three tips on how to actually
execute you've got to learn how to read
widely walk the market look at trends in
the marketplace make connections that
don't seem obvious rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
be a learner over to you Bill Gates also
if you want to hear what Bill Gates and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building confidence check out
my 250 for confidence series yes I
believe in the internet I believe it'll
get increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that every day for the next 254 days
I will send you a 30 second to five
minute video for free every morning to
help you build unstoppable confidence
the link is in the description
it's an incredible time to be a learner
I remember when I was young and I had
the world book which is one of Warren's
products and it was very good but yeah I
always felt like god I want to get into
this more depth I wonder if kind of
better today the videos that are online
and the courses that you can buy with
the very best professors it's phenomenal
you know take a subject like weather or
climate change yeah or what's going on
in economics what's known what's not
known
now with the foundation a lot of what I
need to learn it's about biology making
vaccines and what's going on with these
these various diseases this is a
phenomenal time to be a curious person
the information that's out there you
know I have a my my biggest problem is
that I stay up too late because I'm
reading and then I'm a little bit tired
the next day whatever you say you can't
do is just your Excuse because you're
afraid you can learn anything it's never
been easier to learn anything then right
now I remember being in high school and
my first years of high school still
having to use a library and still having
to see my librarian mrs. Donnelly and
ask for her help in finding a book that
will give me the information that I need
and through University then internet
comes and I'm showing my age a bit 38
years old right now but whatever you
want to learn you can learn the age of
what your parents grew up with is gone
you can learn anything that you want
through the resources available on the
internet right now we profile some of
these people on the channel we profiled
Olympic athletes whose only trainer was
YouTube videos they learn to become
Olympic athletes by watching technique
on YouTube videos while everybody else
lives in the world of I don't have the
resources and I don't have the coach and
I don't have the access to the
information you have it all you're just
afraid it's great that this is a Bill
Gates story because Bill Gates saved my
life Bill Gates saved my business I've
never met the man but in my early days
of being an entrepreneur I struggled I
wanted to quit I had a software company
it was the worst days of my life and I
looked at Bill Gates his story after the
worst day of my life
after I told my business partner that I
quit and I said I can't do this because
I feel like a worthless human being I
quit I'm gonna get some job I woke up
the next day saying I can't quit I have
to find another way to stand and the
revelation I had was I'm not the first
guy to try to sell soft before like
somebody's figured this out and I
modeled Bill Gates and I looked at how
he went from 0 to 1 how did he make his
first million selling software and how
could I model that for myself in a
couple weeks of doing it I had my first
deal for thirteen and a half thousand
dollars and I was making 300 bucks a
month
so 30 and half thousand dollars was was
huge for me
just by modeling the success of Bill
Gates just by asking myself somebody
else has done this before I don't have
to figure out all the answers myself and
so somebody's really figured out the
path that you're going down maybe not
exactly maybe not 100% but they can take
you 90% of the way you have to still
adjust and tweak the strategies but
anything that you want to learn you
can't learn for free it's never been
easier you just have to get over your
fear and putting a little bit of work
but it has never been easier so what are
you waiting for
I'm gonna give you three tips on how to
actually execute tip number one is make
a top 5 list I want you to write down
the five people who you admire the most
the five people who you want to learn
from the five people who you wish you
could get mentorship from whether it's
people in your industry like Bill Gates
might be if you're in software or those
people who you just look up to and
respect and say wow I love Oprah even
though I have nothing to do about TV and
media in that platform I just love her
right to make a top five list find
people who love respect want to emulate
want to learn from wish you can get an
internship with which it gets spent a
day in their life write down those five
people tip number two go to YouTube
type in each of those five people's
names sort the videos by most views and
find ten videos on each person ten
YouTube videos on each of the five
people and then add to your watch later
that is his beautiful playlist that you
can come back to you at any time and
watch it saves it for you for the future
do that for each of the five people now
we've got five people ten videos we've
got fifty videos step number three every
day start your day by watching one of
those videos every day you're getting
filled with knowledge with mindset with
vation with ideas from the people who
you want to learn from you will be the
change person if you woke up every day
and watch the video from somebody who
you respect and look up to if you did
that every single day
you mean that see major growth from day
to day but if you look back over a year
of doing it you will be a completely
changed individual and so the reason to
do it is yes for the learning is yes for
the ideas for the strategies it's it's
Bill Gates's partnership strategy that
helped ultimately build my business
forward but it's also for the motivation
it's also for the inspiration it's also
for the thing that you fear so much they
wanted to be a big software entrepreneur
but never think you can be a Bill Gates
to having the big mission ambition and
then telling yourself that you can't do
it because you're not good enough and
what I found is by looking at these
people who've done so much more than me
by looking as people who are the kings
of five people that I might pick in my
industry people that I look up to and
respect chances are they started off
with less than what I already have right
now these five people on your list
chances are they started off with less
than what you already have right now and
so the strategies and the learnings were
great but the motivation the mindset the
inspiration I found invaluable to help
me move forward and I thickened came for
you too now I've got a really special
bonus scoop that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that I want to know
question of the day who are your five
who's in your top five the people who
you wish could mentor you could guide
you you could internship for leave it
down on the comments below I want to see
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
let's pray so give me go
and the one big lesson I've learned Doug
is that if you just depend on the
traditional strategy strategic planning
cycle or dependent standard set of
consulting reports you actually are
going to do your company a big
disservice and our CEOs and leaders have
to be lifelong students and not just
students in the sense of attending
courses or reading a book or two you've
got to learn how to read widely walk the
market look at trends in the marketplace
make connections that don't seem obvious
and start to paint pictures of what the
future could be and then watch consumer
behavior I'll give you an example ten
years ago or maybe 15 years ago if you
came to PepsiCo I looked at all the
beverages that were being served on the
side tables when we're having meetings
most of the people would be consuming
full sugar beverages about ten years ago
the trend shifted or me
maybe twenty years ago they were
drinking full sugar ten years ago they
shifted to diet drinks okay but five
years ago they were drinking more
bottled water now the point that I'd
make to my guys as guys don't you don't
need to hire a consultant to tell you
where the trends are you just have to
look at our side table remember the
number of facings we used to have a
regular sugar Pepsi versus Diet Pepsi
versus bottled water now if you're all
drinking bottled water or drinking zero
calorie beverages why do we think we are
not representative of the consumer very
often I think what happens is we
separate out the consumer out there from
the consumer in us we are the consumer
and the more we can bring the two
together and say we two are
representative of the consumer outside I
think it would be better we go out and
you know our children play with other
children we see other families and when
they moderate certain products that we
sell in terms of what's given to kids
that's a trend okay so we've got to
watch all of these things and too often
I think as leaders think what
consultants tell us or what certain
reports say or certain books say is the
gospel it's really not we have to become
our own data collectors data analyzers
and then shape
creators and I think that's the toughest
thing because people who are rewriting
the rules have to create the shapes and
people don't like that because they have
a traditional model of how things work
and they hate people who have to upset
status quo and I think both of us are
upsetting status quo in a big way and
you know it's tough but it's fun
learning is a lifelong thing it doesn't
end at Harvard Business School it's your
responsibility I think if you're in any
profession at all you have to do it
consistently all the time I think I
spend probably fifty or sixty percent of
my time learning reading talking to
people traveling that's the only way you
can keep on top of this global world of
ours and it's even tougher now because
of the globality of the businesses
you're all going to deal in how reading
is the most important one but the second
one which is often forgotten is talking
to other people you can learn more from
speaking to people in 15 minutes then if
you spent your life doing something they
could explain it to you and you can
learn from watching people you also are
going to learn by I'm going to call it
imitation but by watching other very
good people and how they operate in
difficult circumstances I learned a lot
of things what not to do analyze what to
do by watching other people altruistic
world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video